starting off this hour is Maria in Los
Angeles hi Maria how are you hi Dave I
have a crazy idea that I got from
listening to your show I want to know
what your thoughts were on selling our
house to pay off our debt and renting
while we save up for a down payment on a
new house I wouldn't do that unless it
was a desperate situation and I hated my
house anyway
do you like my neighborhood you hate
your neighborhood okay so let's let's
pretend you were debt-free except the
home would you move yeah okay so you're
moving anyway is what we're saying yeah
pretty much we love are we like our
house it's the neighborhood is just not
the greatest you would move if you were
debt free yeah so you're moving anyway
it's just a matter of it's just a matter
of when you're moving exactly okay all
right and so I don't know that we're not
necessarily selling the house to get out
of debt we're signing the house to get
out of that neighborhood while we're at
it we may use the money to get out of
debt how much equity do you have in the
home how much cash would it free up if
you sold the house um if we saw we have
about 138 thousand dollars in debt and
we have about maybe 165 in equity on the
house excellent okay and what is the
what is all that debt on mostly student
loans and some vehicles okay have you
been working to get out of debt a while
uh no we just kind of started we have
money saved up in the bank
- yep how much - um saved up in the bank
maybe about $26,000
okay how much credit card debt do you
have um it's very little so that's all I
maybe ten grand or something like that
we must make pretty decent amount of
money why you might one about 155 a year
okay okay so if you sold your home you
would be debt-free and you have thirty
thousand dollars in the bank and you'd
be saving up for a down payment maybe
your later or something is what it
sounds like um that works here's the
possible problem with it and let's
figure out how we can keep that from
happening okay you have not yet
addressed the bad habits that put you
into this debt you have in your mind but
you don't have any
proof that you have changed and your
husband has changed you follow me right
if you had call me episode Dave we've
been getting out of that for six months
we've already paid off $60,000 and we
still got 130 left that would be a
different story than what you're telling
me you're telling me you're brand-new to
this and you you could go back to
spending and being disorganized and not
having a budget like you used to live
and you might get back into debt you
follow me yeah that's that that's the
scary thing about your story so if I'm
you to protect me against me okay I
might say let's sell the house but let's
do it after we reduce the debt X and I
would start with this I would get all
the credit cards out tonight and cut
them all up I would get all excited
doing that I would it doesn't take long
you don't have to start doing it you
just do it it takes about five minutes
and then you'd get on every dollar
budget it takes about ten minutes to do
that and if you live on a written budget
on every dollar with your husband and
you're both in agreement and you can
systematically reduce debt for three or
four months then maybe we go ahead and
sell the house that we're going to sell
anyway and pay off the rest of the debt
and move forward but I'm going to take
10,000 out today and pay off all the
credit cards and cut and cut them all up
that's a first step because see what
that does is that makes your stomach go
because it makes you go oh we're really
doing this this is no longer theory when
you place the scissors across that
stupid plastic and you pull actual real
money out of your real account and you
really pay that debt it's a different
emotion than talking about it in theory
right so let's go ahead and do some real
things if I'm you I want to prime in
your shoes I want to protect me from me
and I don't have any track record that
me is smart yet with money I think you
can be you make good money it's not that
you're dumb people but you haven't been
smart with money yet so let's do 90 days
of smart with money and prove it to
ourselves before we put sell our house
and then I put my house on the market
I don't know april/may something like
that and then execute your plan but if
you get out too easy and you don't
change your habits you're gonna make a
mess of your life and you won't have a
house anymore I don't want you to do
that that's not a plan at all so that
that's how I would handle it and those
are my reasons thanks for calling Maria
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]